also haben sie gerade kam der so was ist
das ich liebe schöne bode sie richtig
aber das ist leider sehr erfrischend
dass das dilemma system ist so ist ich
habe ihn ja dass mehr pepp
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute richtig
leckeres spekulieren so ihr könnt das
ganze in einer runden form machen ich
nehme heute eine eckige ich werde euch
aber alles ganz genau hier unten in die
infobox schreiben genauso wie alle
anderen zutaten natürlich und ich lege
jetzt direkt los ich habe jetzt hier
dieses karamell gebäck das kind schon
aus ein paar videos von mir gibt's ja
auch in nahezu jedem supermarkt dass ich
endlich mal bei kaufland und macht das
auch immer so dass wenn ich mache auch
immer die entziehen schön und dann
streichen wir noch ein paar kekse und
das ist so meine vorratsdosen wo ich das
dann wieder aufsammeln ich werde nichts
verschwenden und genauso sehen sie im
ganzen haus und gleich noch was für die
decke und hiervon nehme ich mir jetzt
erst mal was und wer sie richtig schön
richtig schön verpackt nicht hacken
sondern zu hauen ergebnis in brutal an
aber ich wollte euch zeigen dass das
ganze auch ohne einen mixer geht ihr
könnt auch einfach nur gefrierbeutel
nehmen und dann mit einem nudelholz
drauf hauen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt noch butter in der
mikrowelle zu lassen am besten einfach
die niedrige wattzahl wählen ich bin
immer bei 360 watt und habe immer ein
auge drauf weil sonst die butter einmal
platzt oder nicht die ganze mikrowelle
schmutzig und da gebe ich dann einfach
alles in eine schüssel und vermenge dass
so ein bisschen dass es schöne feuchte
keks masse wird und die kommt jetzt
direkt in die springform ich sie mir wie
gesagt meine eckige springform das
übrigens auch eine neuheit eine zweite
gibt's gleich im video also dieses
videos heute voller überraschungen
unsere ausrichtung springform sind jetzt
auf jeden fall da aber dazu mache ich
euch noch mal extra videos und da
braucht jetzt kein bagdad hier unten
drunter das ist schon das hat eine super
8 eigenschaft und das ist wie ein
gefettet oder dass es eingebettet ist da
gibt es dann die ganze keks masse rein
und dann nehmt ihr euch entweder einen
glas oder einen teig schaber und dann
alles schön glatt streichen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt erst mal die springform
zur seite gelegt und wir machen weiter
mit der leckeren krems übrigens ein sehr
sehr anfänger freundliches rezept heute
und da nehme ich jetzt einfach
schlagsahne die zutaten für meine creme
sind alle kalt also happy schlagsahne
ich habe quark da habe ich diesmal den
20-prozentigen könnte auch magerquark
nehmen das ist einmal der hier könnte
theoretisch gesehen auch den
40-prozentigen es bei diesem rezept
alles kein problem und hier habe ich
mach kaputt bevor ich die beiden zutaten
aber noch dazu gebe mache ich erst noch
folgendes sonst war nehme ich mir mein
handrührgerät können auch die
küchenmaschine nehmen und da gebe ich
jetzt ein bisschen zucker rein und dann
schlage ich das steif und bevor es ganz
steif ist also ihr merkt das wird ein
bisschen steif als ganz steif wird gehen
wir noch die anderen zutaten dazu und
lassen ein bisschen sahne fest ein
riesen
[Musik]
immer wenn haase dann doch mit dem beet
es heißt also entweder zu verkünden oder
hört sich ja schon ärger oder das ist
ein derby
aber das ist jetzt ein werbeblock auf
den jeweilig wahrscheinlich alle freuen
werden wir haben wieder nachwuchs
bekommen die leute fahren wir waren
bekommt den nachwuchs selber schon ohne
in der namensfrage worden und hatten
kinder ist baby wir haben sie auf
instagram
da kriege ich auch immer nachrichten ja
wann kommt die wand kommt dann kommt die
idee starlight rief bahr andere
spekulieren
die scream family wächst und wächst ich
mach mal auf während durchsetzt schaufel
ich einfach mal so ein bisschen zwischen
erzählt von metallica und vor allem auch
ohne palme das ist immer wichtig ich
versuche ja immer versuchen eigentlich
immer die cremes ohne fahne herzustellen
kann sagen möchten schaffen dass also 40
fragt was ist das für eine creme und uns
auf instagram zum beispiel nicht fort es
ist eine spekulatius karamell cremen sie
hier das ganze jahr über löffeln können
am
löffel also also schaufeln schaden
können aber das ist also das ist perfekt
zum backen das ist halt die haselnuss
kinder und natürlich auch auf brot aber
ich muss leider sagen das geht aus einem
richtigen trend gesetzt indem du
angefangen hast mit hasen zu packen wir
machen das sehr viele mit haare skripte
andere aufstrichen wird das zum beispiel
könnte man natürlich auch benutzt du
wirst genau und ich muss sagen es gibt
natürlich auch ganz große firma die auf
solche krems herstellt namens nennen
darf ich weiß dass ich auf jeden fall
mut gehört wir machen unser eigenes ding
machen es besser noch bis heute machen
intensiver
probiert sie einfach schreibt mir bitte
unbedingt euer feedback und in die
kommentare
genau gewusst und sie ist komplett vegan
ich werde jetzt hier vor natürlich auch
was in die cremt euch wahrscheinlich
gedacht okay ist was er da so eine
leckere was so gar nicht mitbekommen
haben sie immer so eine schöne leckere
sana mascarpone qua gesehen und spricht
das einmal natürlich fehlt jetzt hier an
geschmack weitergeht im rezept
[Musik]
ich habe die spekulation auf konter
gerät wenn ich mir am ende unsicherheit
weil man überschlägt er manchmal sein
und dann wird sie grüße dich dann könnt
ihr gerne einfach gegen ende noch einen
teig shopper verwenden und
kosten frisch und lecker und ich hab mir
gedacht dass ich das jetzt noch mal weil
das soll sind tiramisu charakter haben
deswegen habe ich hier einfach kaffee
der ist schon abgekühlt jetzt nehme ich
mir einfach wieder diese karamell kekse
es kommt ja gar nicht dass ich bin total
verwirrt das kommt gleich erst aber im
prinzip schichten wir das jetzt immer
nacheinander wird diesen karamell kick
suchen sie immer für eine sekunde in
kaffee schon ein bisschen aufgeregt
wegen dem launch von der krämer ich
mache jetzt einfach so dass ich das
immer so im schicht und dass ich
wirklich so zwei drei kics schichten
während kohl und dann wird das ganze nur
noch mit der cream abgeschlossen das
zeige ich euch gleich
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt mit creme
abgeschlossen und habe das noch mal
glatt verstrichen übrigens habe ich mich
doch nur für eine gipsschicht
entschieden weil wir haben hier unten
noch die zweite liste auf männer auch
nicht vergessen und jetzt müssen wir das
ganze fühlen lassen mindestens vier
stunden also könnte es quasi vormittags
vorbereiten am nachmittag weiter machen
oder am abend oder in meinem fall machen
einfach morgen weiter aber ich hab grad
die zeit also könnte es auch gerne am
vortag einfach vorbereiten und dann
würde ich einfach mal sagen wenn wir uns
morgen wieder und das kommt in der
zwischen wird einfach in den kühlschrank
und
[Musik]
das tiramisu konnte jetzt so richtig gut
durch kühlen und man sieht auch schon
also es hat sich zwar optisch nicht viel
verändert aber ich finde man sich so ein
bisschen an der struktur an der
oberfläche das ist einfach noch mal
richtig schön sitzt und ein bisschen
fester geworden ist und die kekse sind
natürlich in der mitte auch schön
durchgeweicht und unten auf den keks
boden sind sie schön knackig genauso wie
wir es haben wollten ich werde jetzt das
ganze noch dekorieren und dafür nehme
ich mir einfach noch mal die spekuliert
wird sie für 30 sekunden vielleicht auch
nur 20 sekunden je nachdem wie viel glas
ist in der mikrowelle erwärmen bei 600
back und dann kommt da einfach noch mal
eine richtig schöne deko auch ich bin
dafür übrigens gleich noch einen
spritzbeutel zur hilfe
[Musik]
zwei fahrstreifen dürft euch jetzt nicht
wundern am anfang an das komisch aus
nehmt euch die eine hand einfach zu
stützen und seit er da vielleicht ein
bisschen ruhiger und dann einfach die
streifen ziehen wie gesagt am anfang
sieht es ein bisschen komisch aus und
die wunderschöne optik kommt aber gleich
dann nehmen wir uns nämlich einen
schaschlikspieß und gehen dann immer
immer hoch und runter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir probieren jetzt unseren spekulieren
sagt begeistert also ich bin ich hab
noch also ich weiß schon noch nie aber
doch das ist richtig richtig schöne
kuchen keiner wird das total kuchen
einige seit die revision aber das sieht
richtig schön aus sie fort sodass ich
heftig aus als sie haben seit kam der
sohn
oder möchte ich die waffe warten müssen
doch war mental klar das ist heftig aus
es ist wirklich sehr schön aus die
kommentare leute mich für die tolle zeit
und ich glaube es ist jetzt auf jeden
fall weiter erweiterung also so richtig
schön warm ohne viel aufwand haben jetzt
zeigte sich schnell dass die fiktion
dass er hat nicht das ist die hast du
also ich bin einfach spekuliert ich
liebe schöne wo das sie richtiggehend
vibrieren so am besten ins toreck von
allem was auch der egal welcher sowohl
das ist jetzt leute sehr frisch und ich
weiß nicht ob ich sage dass das die
leckerste tiramisu ist nicht hier ist
habe aber ich bin das leckere als die
normale standard waren in der das meer
tippgemeinschaft ihr dann bist du liebe
ich auch total sind oder bars oder sport
hat es der werbung zu tun dann krems
aber das macht richtig lecker wirklich
sehr
darauf hin zu essen
10.10.10 fernsehen hört hört sie 15 von
10 das ist hier oben also mehr geht ja
ich sage gar nichts ohne spaß leute das
ist eine leckere torten kuchen schaffen
so und besucher aber es ist sehr lecker
wirklich geklärt ist auch michael ecker
aus also wird es laut gemacht hat und
bestätigen dass auch ja warm macht es
nach kommt zu retten sollen und wie
aufwändig jetzt
haben ist der größte kritiker also
leerzeichen stimme dazu ich gebe auch
locker ich glaub mir elf von zehn so
richtig lecker ist doch perfekt ganz
nicht leichter
lecker auch das herausbilden dieses
video sollte eigentlich an einem sonntag
online gehen so wie das halt so mir
kenntnis habe so diskutiert weil sowohl
begnadet die geht schon mit worden weil
wir einfach angst haben weil wir euch
weiß man nie so etwas wie scream angeht
nicht dass die krümel irgendwie
ausverkauftes oder so obwohl wir
eigentlich schon relativ viel aber wir
wissen wir können halt nie mit damit
rechnen dass auch nicht zufällig zu
werden genau und deswegen haben wir das
rezept jetzt vorgezogen ihr seht ist
also quasi vier tage früher könnt euch
die queen gerne bestellen probiert sie
gerne aus ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen und im leben
unserer nächsten rezepten sonntag
[Musik]